in physics and doing some very
interesting work both in kind of
traditional of biophysics and also in
experimental evolution especially in
space looking at how microbes spread out
over over dishes Danielle for the nice
introduction so you asked me to talk
about experimental evolution and I did
some of that with colonies and I talked
about that in the second part a little
bit but I still don't consider myself as
an expert and perhaps not right now but
later over the course of this lecture
they will be sitting here some experts
which actually know much more and so
they should jump in if what I say is
actually wrong or if they can provide
additional examples to what I'm telling
so my idea for this lecture is to first
give you more or less a broad relatively
broad introduction to experimental
evolution how it works and what we can
learn from it that will be the first
part and I actually don't know how long
it takes it might take longer than 45
minutes but then we can take the break
after that even if it takes it a bit
longer right and then in the second part
I'm going to drill into some you know
some of the things I did myself were
just related to spatial degrees of
freedom so it turns out in the first
part most of the things I'm telling you
involve experiments that are well mixed
so we're spirit space doesn't play a
role and you know in physics we also
often often this is the day of the
physics physicist so I will mention
physics a couple of times in physics we
also often start with the assumption of
everything being well mixed globally
coupled and that's a mean field
assumption and then the question is what
happens when you introduce space and in
physics we know that then behaviors can
change dramatically
and so I would raise the question
whether this can also happen for
evolution but now to start let me given
over you over the history this is my
history slide experimental evolution has
been around us for a very long time
humans have been doing this intuitively
when they domesticated animals for
instance and selectively bred them with
a striking results so for instance the
dogs right we have now 400 races of dogs
which dramatically differ from the
ancestor the wolf and by selective
breeding over just ajust 14 to 30
thousand years and humans did this with
a number of prominent examples dogs cats
horses and also with lots of plants like
maize cabbages
so all these word explosion experiments
without humans actually knowing what
they do is somehow accelerated or
experimental evolution and it was
certainly not done for the purpose of
learning anything about experimental
evolution it was a version of
biotechnology in a sense so what I most
I mostly focus on today are experiments
that are actually designed for the
purpose of learning something about
evolution and maybe the first one of the
first one of the first experiments of
this control type which is often
mentioned is due to this guy William
Dellinger dellinger who came up with
this incubator in 1880 so not that much
longer that much later than the origin
of the species and so in this incubator
it actually consists of one to three
containers and these three containers he
he cultured unicellular organisms
three different kinds over the course of
seven years and what he did was he
controlled the temperature he first
started with the temperature at 16
degrees or 17 degrees Celsius and then
slowly raised it over the seven years to
70 degrees and he reported the striking
finding that the so first the ancestors
with which he started they could grow
very well at 16 degrees but not at 70
degrees and at the end of the experiment
he had evolved strains that could do
well at 70 degrees but lost the ability
to grow well at these cold temperatures
so he already observed a trade off so he
first observed amazingly rapid well
strong response to selection and trade
off so that when you adapt to one
environment you often do words and
others but this experiments had a couple
of drawbacks that plate I think many
evolution experiments until the 1960s
which is there were no replicates really
there was just one instance of this
evolution experiment was reported what
was seen the strains were not frozen so
there's no record of those strains and
actually accidentally the whole thing
that destroyed at 1886 and so no traces
are left except for what this guy wrote
up so then in the 1960s evolution
experiments started to become much more
controlled and people started to realize
that it's important to have replicates
big populations and relatively large
times and still we are now in a phase in
an exciting phase where these
experiments go towards ultimate ation
where you use robots to handle many many
different replicates hundreds thousands
or even micro fluidics where you can go
to millions of replicates and
and also other high-throughput measured
methods that I will mention later that's
the history as far as I understand it
and then how does the experimental
evolution work it works essentially like
real evolution except that there's an
experimenter that controls the
environment and the the initial
condition and the experimental regime
under which evolution happens so all
these experiments are in a way versions
can you see this red dot actually it's
very faint right sorry it's fine so this
is a literal picture of what is done in
often in a standard microbial evolution
experiment so you grow a particular
strain which you define a set of strains
in a couch culture here is to be well
mixed so no space space is not relevant
if you mix if you shake that culture
very well you grow it up until
stationary face for instance then you
dilute it grow again for a certain time
which you define diluted and so on and
most evolution experiments have flavors
of this growth solution and repetition
what you have to do is you have to
define your initial condition and they
are very some very popular model
organisms and why they are popular I
will mention later on also ecoli budding
yeast form C elegans food fly and then
you can also decide whether you want to
start with a single ancestral isogenic
strain or whether you want to start with
some pre-existing standing variation and
that has important differences that is
important differences in the dynamics of
adaptation because obviously if you
start with just one ancestral genotype
then you have to wait for mutations to
come in
until something happens
finally define the experimental regime
define how the size of the population
that you want to evolve the number of
generations for which it should evolve
and the type of selection you you
suggest the subject this population to
so so in this case it's nearly die
Lucien so you grow them on a certain
condition and then you dilute them so
you're selecting for growing very well
under these conditions but you can think
of other types of selection directional
selection if you breed dogs then you
select four dogs of certain traits or I
show other examples actually on the next
slide and then of course it's crucial to
replicate the whole thing to be able to
distinguish whether what you see is just
really chance or whether it's actually a
typical result that you see so what are
typical outcomes so I will go Neuros
through a couple of examples to make a
couple of points that have been observed
by experimental of evolution first of
all if you if you take populations of
higher organisms withstanding variation
and start to adapt them to certain
conditions then you can see or observe
very strong response to selection so for
instance in the first case the fruit fly
was selected for increasing flying
speeds in a wind tunnel essentially so
so imagine lots of flies in this
container and then you start flowing air
through this tunnel then only the
strongest one the ones that flow fastest
that fly fastest will be able to reach
this end of the chamber and then the
experimenter comes in and creams of
these these flies and transfers it to
the next generates those and it turns
out that
the course of hundred generations you
can increase like the top flying speeds
from that amount to 1.7 units per second
so that's a very large increase in these
flying speeds pretty impressive I would
say I don't know what the population
size is in the bottlenecks you are
fortunately I know about this time scale
yeah well then there are funny things
done like here's selection for voluntary
real running in mice
so mice are observed so they are
presented with a wheel and it's
essentially the mice are selected that
voluntarily enter this wheel and
essentially what's counted as per day
the number of wheel revolutions that a
given mice carries out and the ones that
do the most are selectively bred and
that experiment runs since 98 and now
runs for over 65 generation and the
number of voluntary wheel revolutions or
has been increased by a factor of three
wasn't pretty amazing and similar
results can be observed for endurance
running in mice and there might many
other examples of this type and it's
essentially consistent with I think what
was known before namely that humans were
able to selectively breed for instance
dogs or crops and that the response to
the selective breeding was very very
fast if you have a standing variation
present now these were the first and
what are controlled lab experiments
where you can quantify this response to
selection and they are done in the lab
now next I would like to mention one of
the very few field evolutionary
it has actually been carried out yes I
know sometimes people say that there's
like some universal patterns and how the
response to selection slows down over
time I don't know much about it I could
imagine that if you the standing
variation runs out this is your
selection then you know the response
might slow down and then you have to
wait for input of new mutations exactly
yeah I could imagine this this happens
but I don't know does anybody know oh
yeah sure so like speed of light like
there's a really old corn experiment
that's been going on for like 100 years
now and they've you see like being up on
protein and oil or down on protein oil
and basically you know you can't get
below zero oil you can get very close to
it actually but there is a physical
limit but then also I mean with some of
these way before you hit any obvious
physical limit it'll slow down and the
expression is people think it's what
Oscar says monkey your head and on
okay but you don't see a change in the
slope of adapt taken like initially you
select only on standing radiation that's
exactly what I think you were saying
that like it's just because there's some
amount of standing variation in the
beginning population doing by the number
of individuals and then you start
getting rid of that if you have more
individuals you have more variation to
begin with you can also mutations are
coming and also acting more mutations
yeah all right so but these are lab
experiments I want to mention that later
on I will mention artifacts that come in
because we are doing lab experiments and
because we are using lab organisms so
actually what is very valuable are that
is field experiments but unfortunately
they are just very very few and so I
mentioned I think a classic example now
which is a coupie field experiment so
coupie is a certain type of fish and
this experiment was done by John endler
started and I think 78 and he before he
started the experiment he had realized
that the male part of the species has
varying numbers of spots like here these
blue spots very hard to see but these
are colorations essentially - I guess
the attractive but he realized that the
number of spots that you
observe on these male individuals
depends on the type of predators that
are around so in the rivers he has been
looking at there were two types of
predators on the one hand cichlid fish
which are really reminisce predators of
these fish and the other species is
called Revo loose and but this species
only eats juveniles which don't have
these spots yet and he realized that in
rivers without any private creditors or
with this predator present the number of
spots was much higher than when in the
river there were cichlids around okay so
he had the hypothesis that these
predators
select essentially for the presence of
these predators selects four copies of a
certain number of spots and he wanted to
test this in actually both a kind of lab
experiment which is the first one I
described and a field experiment so in
the first one he collected groupies from
18 location and several rivers and he
brought them to ten different ponds
greenhouse ponds that he had at home and
he grew them jointly in the absence of
any predators for a couple of months I
think here you see it for nine months
and recorded the number of spots that he
see that's the initial line here so here
it's plotted the number of spots per
fish as a function of time and this
number was increasing in this first
period okay where they were grown
jointly and then the real experiment
starts where the ponds were subdivided
these ten points they had been he
defined four ponds where he added
reviews this relatively harmless
predator for ponds where he added
cichlids and two ponds which were just
control plants and then he observed the
number of sports over time further and
he observed what he
the size namely that in the control
points and in the reveal Oh spawns the
number of spots further increased in the
ponds of the cichlids it went down and
there was a lab experiment control there
were even some replicates that he has
done quite laborious but he even read
replicated this experiment than in the
field so in the Arriba River in Trinidad
he looked around and he found in some
side streams of that river he found
streams that it's hard to his young here
unfortunately that contained guppy
within the presence of reviewers this
harmless predator Cappy and within the
presence of cichlids with relatively few
spots and copies without any predators
around as well and he found a point that
contained cichlids but no copies yet
okay and what he did was he transferred
Guppies from the river that contained
only reviewers rather no I'm sorry what
effectively bit so the key experiment
was to take a GU piece from a river that
contained these revenues predators where
the spot size was small and he
transferred those to a stream that
contained this relatively harmless
predator and he came back two years
later and observed that the number that
the spot size increase so I mentioned
this whole experiment because it's
really one of the fuels they have a real
field evolution experiment you start
with a controlled lab evolution
experiment and you obtain a result but
often then you don't know where they
translates to realize to nature and he
went into the field
and it verified his hypothesis with this
kind of experiment I don't know if any
other experiments isn't it wasn't
mentioned in my source they said a
couple of generations of fish are a
couple of generations of fish elapsed
over a period of time I don't know how
many unfortunately order 10 I guess yes
so what did he do in the field
natural selection because of changing
sizes of right
but did he modify values so then it
doesn't counts as an exponent
it's just observing what's happening in
nature that's not enough you have to do
a real experiment okay that's that's
really one way of learning about
evolution just watching in the wild and
collecting data and trying to interpret
in terms of evolution but the other one
is really to do an experiment that's a
research tool essentially and here I
mean this kind of this kind of
experiment of course raised ecological
concerns and ethical concern can you do
that just take some species here and
bring it to Australia probably many
species that you bring to Australia
would suddenly proliferate a lot but
cause many problems sorry yeah it's I'm
not saying that this is not strong
evidence for for it for the hypothesis
that he had that's not what I'm saying
but I'm saying it's not an evolution
experiment I'm talking about evolution
spans it's only the topic I was supposed
to talk about the connection is the more
spots you have the more shiny you are
and the more easy to you are identified
by the predator that was the hypothesis
sorry I should have started
compared to the control yeah there are
no arrow bars here well he had
replicates but in this plot
unfortunately you cannot see the
variation between the replicas but I
guess it's not significant back now back
to lab experiments so what we've seen
before were experiments that modified in
a way quantitative characters number of
sports flying speeds and flies things
that you can quantify and we just want
certain number to increase over time
through evolution but a whole other
subject is where they can evolve real
novelty key innovations let's say can
you evolve for instance multicellularity
or can you evolve speciation and many
things have been attempted typically
what's reported of those that are
successful so I'm showing you how to
evolve multicellularity in for instance
yeast but let me just mention there also
for instance pation that has been tried
apparently a number of times but there
were no very successful as well my
source told me that there are no
successful evolution experiments so far
that could evolve spacian obligate
sexuals yeah i think so okay but you
know evolution of multicellularity so
this is a relatively recent experiment
involving budding yeast which has been
involved with ten lines replicate lines
were evolved for sixty round of
selection and the type of selection was
special so these yeasts were grown and
test-tubes is done normally but then
after they grown to saturation they are
allowed to stand on the bench for on the
order of an hour and then over the
course of time the yeast cells are due
to gravity settling down but when they
clump when they cluster together they
are settling down faster and so the
selection that was applied here was to
take to transfer to new medium only
those cells that are present in the
lower part of these test tubes for 60
rounds and what they found is the
evolution of these snowflake yeast and
they are obviously clusters of yeast
cells but they stick together not just
by sticking but they don't separate
after division that's that sort of
feature that evolved here and they
further evolved these snowflakes over
time and could observe the evolution of
a couple of other life history traits
like the reproduction of these clusters
eventually was carried out through
proper tools which were still
multicellular almost not like germ cells
because they were still multicellular
but it started to really look like
multicellular like aspects of
multicellularity there was some no
comments that okay with the yeast that
perhaps not such a big surprise because
yeast had seemed multicellularity but
now they repeated essentially the same
experiment with Chlamydomonas a green
algae which presumably has not seen
multicellularity before and they could
also observe the evolution of clusters
which then in this case actually
reproduced by unicellular propagules
which i guess are these guys and they
are thinner typically similar to the
unicellular once they started they argue
that the evolution of these proper fuels
really is not driven by yep
having unicellular propagules it's often
argued that this is beneficial to avoid
conflict between cells but they argue
here that evolution of these sink
unicellular probably yours
evolved as at one for a different reason
because it simply increases the growth
rate of these clusters if you have these
means having a proper gills around and
as a side effect you also reduce the
conflicts between these cells alright so
that it was a success story as well and
there are many other things that people
have evolved yes it's our you know
you're not going to talk about evolving
diversity or evolving divergence if you
mentioned evolving species and yoga in
obligate sexuals okay that's tough
they're hard to work with mm-hmm but
then like with with microbes there have
been experiments really successfully
evolved like diverse morphologies I
think that's kind of it I will not talk
o-chem okay so much you want you can
comment on this oh yeah oh just maybe it
maybe it's it just to avoid giving
people the wrong impression
so it's pc8 speciation and
diversification or not exactly the same
thing speciation may be hard for
technical reasons without the good
sexuals but diversification and
experimental evolution is pretty easy
others I hope you can reference there if
you like Paul Rainey by or about the
Coulter well in these cases you don't
actively spatially separate them you
just don't actively stir them and then
naturally they do it on their own then
even when you actively stir them so like
the rich les geeks Rams I guess you're
building up to I don't want to spoil it
if you're gonna talk about
diversity they're not so much okay so
then they're even in these experience
where they actively stir them they still
see like genetic diversity persisting
over long periods of time longer they
would plausibly be if it was just purely
neutral so that suggests that there is
some kind of diversification going on
even if it's tough to see when you're
mixing them all together all right
yes form phenotypes yes so this the
phenotype is simply growing these
clusters and eventually these clusters
reproduce by sending out these proper
use and then you go somewhere else and
grow again clusters yes
so it seems like this election pressures
are kind of artificial yes directed yes
it's set by the experimenter but sort of
here the problem was you know can we do
this yeah so I'm giving a give you a
spectrum of evolution experiments so
this one maybe it belongs to a class of
directed selection evolution experiments
where like the fly experiment you go in
and select a particular trait you know
naturally that doesn't happen but you
know then there I will tell you I will
talk a lot about one particular
microbial evolution experiment where the
type of selection is more natural of
that kind simply diluting them diluting
the population the ones that grow faster
get selected it's too artificial I
remember it's not really looks already
it's thank you for sinking right there's
that's a pretty natural thing to select
for there's lots of cases where like the
top of some liquids came washed away or
skimmed off and only the things that
settle to the bottom get to stay now
they even write in the paper that what
they do is not because they think that
their type of selection is it's quite
natural and okay has occurred they only
do it because they can do it very well
in the lab it's very easy to do and it
shows this phenotype so that I think the
surprise is the price of these papers
and there's another one which ended a
little bit differently was that you can
do it and you can do lots of other
things by watching evolution happened
in action and with this let me just oh
yeah let me go essentially to another
important aspect what important thing
that you can learn with evolution
experiments you can test hypotheses and
theoretical papers out about evolution
have generated numerous hypotheses that
are also partially contradicting each
other so you would like to carry out
evolution experiments to verify or
falsify these hypotheses and in this
paper here they have a very very long
list of those hypotheses and ways how
they were tested in the organism here
and the reference so I invite you to
look at those but let me mention for
instance let's go there and sex and
recommendation accelerate adaptation to
a novel environment and that has been
tested in various organisms and you know
with many of these hypotheses the
question is just you have to look long
enough and in different systems and
eventually you'll find it so the real
question is whether the hypothesis that
you're formulating is like typically
true and important in many systems or a
really rare exception and that gets you
into quantitative questions and I will
argue that really some of the most
interesting questions in experimental
evolution are really quantitative and I
think we're entering an exciting stage
of getting more of you know evolving or
in the pushing this instrument further
to make more quantitative statements
rather than just watching evolution
happen one instance and then and then
that's it because it could be just rare
the question is you know if you ask
yourself can I wall something
then I guess definitely the answer is
yes if you just wait long enough then
you will be able to do it but the real
question is how long do you have to wait
so it's often it brings it to a question
of timescales and how likely it is to
evolve and these are quantitative
questions which are really the most as
far as I'm concerned the most exciting
ones so let me maybe summarize the areas
of application of experimental
evolutions on the one hand it's
biotechnology so selective breeding is
what humans have done for a long time
was a way is a version of biotechnology
then vaccines are only routinely or have
been routinely generated by evolving
pathogens and either in media or in some
hosts different from humans in order to
make them less virulent until you can
use them as live attenuated vaccines and
with this experimental evolution has
saved millions of lives so it was very
important in this as things still is
then it's been used to test hypothesis
as I mentioned it's been used as
developing as proof of principle
experiments can be involve
multicellularity yes we can in a week
and the speciation no it hasn't been we
haven't been able to do this so well but
as I argued just now the real important
question I think our quantitative what
you really ask is can be a lot of
multicellularity in a reasonable time
frame and what we can do in a
experimental evolution experiment and
with multicellularity we can do this
speciation not so far not so that brings
me to this question of how can we
quantify evolution using these
experiments how can we quantify rates
and types of evolutionary
and I use and if you're interested in
those quantitative question that brings
you naturally to microbes and evolution
of microbes which is what I focus
actually on in the rest of my talk
before I mention that before I mention
the microbes first time let me summarize
a couple of quantitative questions that
can be addressed in microbial evolution
because how fast the populations are
that obviously how fastest change the
evolution of change of these populations
what are the key parameters that control
this evolutionary dynamics how many
roots are there towards adaptation how
you know is that it's at just one root
and if you have replicates you always go
this route if your death or other many
different routes what are the
consequences mechanism of adaptation is
to just increase Fitness or the other
traits that evolve what is the rate of
spectrum of beneficial mutations
how do mutations interact is there
epistasis and very strong and can we
quantify that these are just one of some
of the qualitative questions you can ask
and in order to answer these questions
it's really natural to focus on microbes
the reason is that microbes have a very
fast very small generation times on
equalise just 20 minutes and under good
conditions in yeast it's 90 minutes then
by definition microbes are small in size
which means that can cultivate very
large populations and the larger the
population the larger the influx of
mutations are some kinds of the larger
expected rate of evolution there's often
excellent genetics particular for model
organisms you can use genome based tools
to find mutations you have females
microbes often forms of multicellularity
veraciously yeah we see
excellent genetics tools of genetics so
if you want to if you observe an
adaptation you want to know okay what
specific mutation is it that gave rise
to the Senate a big change and not much
stuff for ya or if you want to like
manipulate the genetics oh that is also
someone put in something to make it
easier to work with if you have an odd
purposes that certainly mutation is
responsible for a certain adaptation
then you can put in this mutation into
the ancestor and verified it
the ancestors can be frozen down and um
during the course of evolution
experiment you can freeze down the
derive strains and that allows you to
reconstruct the path of evolution you
can replay evolution but starting from
ancestors for certain state and you can
do many many replicants so these are all
advantages they're also disadvantages
with of doing roofing experiments with
lab strains in particular which I've
mentioned later and microbial evolution
experiments typically look like this in
this review there are three different
types highlighted so in one hand you
have an evolution experiment where
really adaptation was prevented from
happening this is these are mutation
accumulation experiments so you start
with a microbial culture on a petri dish
you streak out these microbes and then
you streak them when you do this
thoroughly then you find single colonies
which have derived from single cells now
this car after a short period of time of
growth you then take the single colony
streak it out on a new plate to again
look for colonies that have derived from
a single cell
and by this procedure you are
introducing very very strong bottlenecks
in the course of this evolution
experiment so that's flooded here the
population size you decide essentially
after each transfer you start with just
one cell grow the population and then
choose again a very very strong
bottleneck and there's still selection
happening which means if mutations come
in that have an impact on on the growth
rate they will you know then selection
will act in these periods of growth but
this time delta T is relatively small
then it is typically assumed that in
this experiment what you see the
evolution changes you see simply reflect
the spectrum of mutations that are
coming in so these experiments are
carried out to the tool to understand
the spectrum of mutations really if you
want to see adaptation then you have two
generic types of carrying out your
evolution experiment one is a continuous
culture this is a chemostat where medium
is added in at a constant rate and at
the same rate culture is taken out so
that the population size fluctuates
around the steady-state and that's a
continuous culture and the alternative
to that is a cereal transfer experiment
which I mentioned before you start
adding microbes to fresh medium let them
grow and then dilute let them grow and
so on so there are lots of technical
problems with these continuous cultures
to for instance avoid contamination so
that this is considered a very robust
way it's a bit unfortunate that you
always have these bottlenecks and you
always typically because delta T is
typically one day you can hardly avoid
that to enter stationary state so you
cannot it's hard with this to maintain
continuously exponentially growing
population
all right yeah I think that's one of the
artifacts that you might be looking at
when you look at laboratory selection so
so in a couple of slides I mentioned you
know issues that cannot with lab
experiments especially can you translate
these results to natural populations for
the reasons that you mentioned that's
one of the reasons to mention is let's
take a really short break be back here
at ten and thank her for the